this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by enlisted
September 14 1994 was a quiet night in
Zimbabwe then suddenly what sounded like
an explosion startled people all over
the country Windows rattled and door
shook shocked and Confused people
nervously stepped out of their homes to
see what happened but everything looked
fine they went back inside to bed but
one woman wasn't satisfied Cynthia hind
drove around the capital city of Harare
looking for the source of the sound but
nothing seemed unusual but back at home
Cynthia's phone rang relentlessly she
was a UFO investigator and witness
reports were coming in one after the
other the news claimed that the sound
was a sonic boom caused by a meteor
shower but Cynthia wasn't so sure
eyewitnesses near Lake Kariba described
bizarre lights in the sky earlier that
week lights in a row that moved
erratically fast then slow first north
to south then East to Southwest meteors
don't do that Cynthia suspected there
was much more to the story and two days
later she'd find out she was right thank
you
[Music]
a human oh thank goodness I get through
something very important I can't
understand you hang on hang on I don't
have good reception how's that better
what are you doing you're supposed to be
on a plane coming back here well Gertie
now what well what a blue shirt that the
TSA told me no camels were allowed well
she's an emotional support camel yeah I
don't know she wouldn't fit through the
air the see-through machine so they had
to uh
I'd say hang on are you crying
are you creating you know the way
it is
I know baby I know it's over now Daddy's
here well I'm sorry they did that did we
get on the plane and he told me she has
to go under the seat how is she supposed
to Sir is a bridge too far didn't she
suffer enough indignity for one day look
I'm sorry about that but I'm not sure
how I'm supposed to help you pal oh I
got it handled uh but I need you to get
my computer you remember my password you
mean password yes my password no I mean
okay I'm in what am I doing all right
opened up and list it for me and finish
invading Normandy invading wait
is this today's sponsor it sure is
enlisted is a
shooter game ooh I like World War II
stuff but is it accurate you've been
your primate patody it is all the
equipment uniforms locations and
vehicles are historically authentic and
you have to use them the way they would
use back then you can also customize all
your stuff based on your name skills and
inventory wait who do I play there's
like six different soldiers here oh yeah
Moon
soldiers give them orders and assume
control of any individual soldier in
your squad at the Press of a button when
that guy dies just take control of
another guy you don't have to respawn
until the whole Squad is wiped out all
right I'm ready how do I do it just
click the link in the description to
download and list it for free on PC
PlayStation 4 and 5 and Xbox One and
series X and S there's an exclusive
bonus with this link too three days of
Premium Time and orders for troops and
weapons all right I'll finish up
Normandy for you and then I'll set up my
own Squad but uh how are you gonna get
back to the States
worry about me and Gertie we got a plan
I know honey I know just just don't look
down
the town of Rua is located about 14
miles Southeast of Zimbabwe's Capital
Harare surrounded by Farmland Rua is a
small agricultural Community but not
poor the more affluent families in the
area sent their children to Aerial
school a private Academy for grades one
through seven or ages 6 through 12. oh
wait a minute they name the school after
that redhead chick with the purple
pasties no the Archangel Ariel did she
wear purple pasties oh I'm sorry did I
use the wrong pronouns 2023 is so
annoying
September 16th was a quiet sunny day at
aerial school and the students were at
morning recess some kids were kicking
soccer balls others were playing tag or
hanging out under the trees the teachers
were in a meeting so the kids had the
yard to themselves a few minutes after
10 the children noticed a strange
buzzing noise at first it seemed to come
from everywhere it sounded like a swarm
of bees or faulty electrical lines the
children were nervous but then the sound
stopped but a few minutes later the
sound was back and much louder than
before the kids looked around for the
source and they are hovering above the
trees was an object witness accounts
vary but some saw a bright streak others
saw a glowing disc but all agreed a
mysterious object with flashing lights
was descending beyond the tree line
naturally the children drifted toward
the woods for a closer look through the
brush they saw a metallic saucer-shaped
craft slowly land in a rocky field just
beyond their play area then the buzzing
stopped other children in the yard
became a aware of the commotion hearing
shouts of I see it and there it is
subconsciously the children gathered
together pooling their bravery and
walked slowly toward the object then
they stopped Frozen with fear two
figures were standing outside the craft
and those figures weren't human
hundreds of people today phoned the zbc
and the BBC correspondent in Harare
saying they cited an unidentifying
flying object last night with some
eyewitness reports it was a bright
radiant flight I've never seen anything
like it in my life it was it was the
absence of noise I didn't like
the craft sat silently in the brush
beyond the fence line two beings about
four feet tall emerged from the silver
object they were dressed in dark
tight-fitting suits they had large heads
with no ears and very small noses and
mouths Their Eyes Were big almond shaped
and completely black the creatures were
walking back and forth around their ship
as if looking for damage alien pit crew
nice well they didn't seem to notice or
care much about the children until some
of the younger students started
screaming then the creature stopped
turned and looked right at the group of
kids waiting by the fence the younger
children ran screaming back toward the
school but the older students stood
there watching staring Sama a fifth
grader wanted to run and protect her
younger siblings but she could move she
was doing everything in her power to
escape but something about the big black
eyes and the visitors kept her in place
big
head and big black eyes and was dressed
in a black bodysuit
then completely against her will she
felt herself take a step forward at the
same time one of the beings took a step
toward her
she felt like this being was probing her
mind looking for something mind control
something like that yeah
it protects me from government spying
and mind control it also happens to be
tricked on nuts
Google it
twelve-year-old Liesel was frozen in
place she felt the space and time around
her distort as ringing in her ears grew
louder and louder then like frames of
the movie images flashed through her
mind images of some kind of catastrophe
on Earth she saw people screaming in
cities burning then an image of millions
of trees burned to Cinders and of the
oceans boiling Emma was standing next to
Liesel watching in silence instinctively
she grabbed liesel's hand at that moment
images crashed into her mind she saw
technology she didn't understand but she
knew it was bad she saw smoke bodies
lying in streets she was terrified she
willed her legs to move to run away but
she couldn't she didn't feel stuck but
felt like she was floating like her feet
weren't touching the ground there was no
way to run Emily a fifth grader felt
like all the air around her was gone she
had to remind herself to breathe she
thought she might pass out she was aware
of the other children next to her but
they seemed so far our way the only
sound she could hear was the blood
pumping in her ears she knew she needed
to run but there was something about
those big black eyes she couldn't look
away Sama took another step forward then
she heard a message in her mind no words
but she still understood the being
wanted her to come closer so she took
another step at that moment she sensed
the beings wanted her to go with them
although it seemed only like a minute or
two 15 minutes had passed suddenly the
school bell rang indicating recess was
over the creatures glanced at the school
and the children snapped out of their
trance then reality came crashing in and
the children panicked they ran screaming
back to the school they burst into the
hallway yelling their story to anyone
who would listen the teachers came out
of their meeting and it was chaos When
the Children finally calmed down they
explained what happened the teachers ran
out to the yard but they were too late
[Music]
around 10 a.m on September 16th during
recess 62 students from aerial School
saw one or more shiny silver craft
descend into a Brushy field near the
playground
sitting on the spaceship I didn't know
it was a spaceship wasn't it a
helicopter or something like that well
it looked like it was like like a disc
like a round and whereabouts was it oh
the medicine and the trees over there
between the third pole and did you girls
see that as well
several students said the craft was
surrounded by smaller objects sipping
around the sky these objects had
flashing colored lights they were moving
slowly and would disappear then reappear
somewhere else it seemed like the
objects and the beings were guarding the
saucer or maybe trying to fix some kind
of malfunction immediately after the
incident the Headmaster of the school
Colin Mackey told the children to draw
what they saw and write down everything
they could about what happened this
would prove very helpful in future
investigations reports varied but all
shared course similarities a number of
beings emerged from the craft the beings
were humanoid with large heads small
mouths and large dark oval eyes wearing
tight black suits some of the children
said there was a being walking or
running around the top of the craft
others said it was moving around on the
ground but the way the beings moved was
strange we saw this black figure running
in a slow motion the strange thing was
emotion
the way the beings moved Spooks some of
the younger children and they began to
cry and scream this Drew even more
attention from the other students nearby
it also drew the attention of the beings
then the children noticed the being in
front of the craft was looking back and
even though its mouth didn't move the
children heard it in their minds the
adults at aerial school didn't know if
the children had seen a UFO in Aliens
but they believed they saw something I
agree that it could be something that we
are not common with
the event happened on a Friday and over
the weekend some parents were searching
the field behind the school looking for
physical evidence they did find some
flattened brush but that could have been
caused by anything when Colin Mackey got
to work on Monday morning his desk was
covered with letters and messages from
parents demanding to know what terrified
their children some students were so
traumatized they wouldn't return to
school for a few days a couple of
students wouldn't return it all Colin
Mackey knew that he had to get to the
bottom of whatever this was he had to
make sense of it to solve it but to do
that he would need help
there were roughly 100 kids in the
playground broad daylight aerial School
Rose and bobwe 1994 and they got within
arms armed some of them within arm's
length of these beings but those kids
the way they were talking about it the
way they were drawing it you're like wow
it really does seem like something
happened to that I get goosebumps still
to this day after spending over six
years investigating this case it just
gives me the Goosebumps when I see that
because you know those kids aren't lying
in the few days after the loud sound was
heard all over Zimbabwe Cynthia hind
would continue to study witness reports
of the supposed meteor shower Professor
Ewan Nesbit who worked at the Greenwich
observatory in London told her that a
Russian satellite had entered Earth's
atmosphere as the satellite burned up it
caused strange lights in the sky and
what sounded like an explosion some
pieces of the satellite were actually
recovered in the city of keroy outside
of Harare but a disintegrating satellite
didn't match the descriptions given by
the witnesses we saw this like the
silver thing down there it was a silver
oval thing that flew past really slowly
I saw the bigger one and the spaceship
like four or five of them it was red
green and yellow there was this big ship
it had these lights these patterns and
it flew the news outlets had encouraged
witnesses to call with any information
they had about the mysterious object
hundreds of people call the local
television station and the BBC station
in Harare what they reported did not
resemble a meteor shower these things we
are flying in a pattern and there was no
sound no wings no nothing shining over
things
as the Continental coordinator from
mufan the mutual UFO Network Cynthia had
her own theories about what might have
been seen in the sky that night but she
needed more evidence two days later came
an electrifying call from Tim Leach the
BBC bureau chief for Zimbabwe hello
hello my name is Tim Lee from BBC
television news
um I understand that you had some
strange experience is that right
he was a respected journalist a seasoned
reporter who covered War zones yet on
this call he sounded rattled Tim told
Cynthia that 62 students at the aerial
School in Rua had seen a UFO invited her
to join him at the school to talk to the
children of course she agreed but even
after 20 years as a UFO investigator
she'd never seen anything like this
Tim Leach was a cameraman and producer
who had covered war-torn parts of Africa
like Angola Rwanda and Nigeria for the
BBC he was familiar with gunfire intense
situations he even witnessed the deaths
of several colleagues despite his
experience Tim was unsure about how to
proceed the BBC is known for fact-based
reporting if you think the media is
reporting facts I have an nft to sell
you well they require multiple sources
to run a story
you count Anonymous sources Tim had over
60 sources actual sources yet the story
still wasn't considered credible local
reporters weren't taking it seriously
well unless it's a story about cow
thoughts and global warming they take
that very seriously yeah I don't want to
have this conversation now
even Tim Leach a self-proclaimed realist
and skeptic couldn't make sense of the
aerial School UFO Incident That's when
Cynthia Hein suggested they contact Dr
John Mack
Jim Leach from BBC television news and
Harare Zimbabwe message for Dr John Mack
This concerns a UFO sighting over a
school
where it's hovered banded a black man
got out but of course we're having
difficulty being taken seriously in
spite of being the BBC please call me as
soon as you can thank you
Dr Mack was a psychiatrist who
specialized in child psychology in the
early 90s he conducted a 10-year
psychological study on individuals who
claimed to have experienced encounters
with aliens these encounters often
recurred and even involved abductions Dr
Mack believed that Society especially
academics shouldn't dismiss these
reports as mere mental or cognitive
issues again the whole thing has made me
re-examine all of these Notions of
happen didn't happen for them it is
completely real and it is not the
product of mental illness now whether it
happened altogether in this reality I
don't know but it shows up in their
world there there seem to be missing by
Witnesses at the time so something is
occurring that is entering our world
the teachers felt that it was unlikely
for 62 students to come up with such
nuanced and similar stories together
Cynthia hind had also noted that if all
these kids had told the exact same story
it would suggest that they had conspired
and fabricated it while she acknowledges
that some students may have added or
embellished details she believed that
the core of what each child claimed to
have seen remained the same and that
what they saw was very creepy the figure
on the ground approached them and
stopped just a few feet away the
children said it stared intently at them
at all of them and this was unsettling
to some kids and downright scary to
others and Dr Mack interviewed some
students who were visibly upset when
recalling the encounter the children
also felt the being was trying to send
them a specific message and even put
images into their minds Dr Mack found it
interesting that the message sent to the
children didn't offer any solutions only
a warning there was no suggestion as to
how to address pollution oh what did
Greta Thunder go to this school she
wasn't even born yet how dare you Dr
Mack felt this lack of agenda made the
children's stories about the encounter
more sincere one girl tried to explain
what the being was telling her about
humans impact on the planet Dr Mack was
encouraged he asked if there's anything
we as a people can do with that love to
help the Earth unfortunately the answer
was no
[Music]
foreign
weeks following the encounter Ariel's
School became inundated with UFO fever
the media swarmed locals speculated but
authorities clung to Conventional
explanations the official story was a
meteor shower from two nights before
seeded Mass hysteria a few students
concocted at elaborate imaginary tale
that cut on with the rest of the school
parents were divided some refused to
believe their children but others took
the story more seriously many locals
chalked it up to mischievous Spirits
like the Shona tikaloche a dwarf from
Zulu mythology with a large head and
pointed ears holy men suggested ancient
shrines nearby had drawn the craft they
claimed that mysterious events have been
happening in the area for years either
way most residents believed something
Supernatural had occurred whether it was
aliens or not the teachers and
investigators believed the children had
some kind of experience and similar
reports were made before and after the
school sighting
what the hell is that
two days before the aerial encounter 100
students at the Pier House school only
25 miles away saw a flying object flying
very low to the ground as if it was
going to land at the same time the
school and bus Radio Systems stopped
working that same day during daylight a
mother and her young child said they saw
a UFO in the area and a truck driver
reported seeing strange beings on the
roadside that night when he was driving
but the story of the aerial School UFO
incident isn't perfect many students
agreed on some details but the stories
had a lot of variations and
contradictions some students saw the
beings but not the craft some describe
the object in detail but don't remember
any beings or entities of any kind some
students playing in the yard at the very
same time saw nothing at all the
students that did see the object
couldn't decide if it was one or more
most students thought the object was a
ship or a craft but they couldn't agree
on how it looked some kids drew windows
and doors other children saw lights and
landing gear two boys said the ship
wasn't silver it was black with green
stripes one child said it was red at
least two students heard a loud noise in
the sky some said it was a buzzing sound
like bees another said it sounded like a
flute as for the beings or Pilots or
aliens or whoever they were some
students said they had long black hair
while others saw no hair at all some
kids said the beings were fat some said
they were thin one student said the
being looked like a shadow and there was
no agreement on how many there were and
Dr Mack's participation in the case is
also problematic he didn't arrive at the
school until months after the event
meanwhile the students had spoken to
lots of people been interviewed by the
media and Drew countless pictures of
what they saw and that's plenty of time
for the story to evolve and when Dr Mack
finally arrived he interviewed the
children in small and large groups where
they would just agree with each other's
stories and Dr Mack had a reputation for
asking very leading questions he did the
same thing when he spoke to the children
in Brazil who said they saw an alien in
the town of Virginia vagina
before Dr Mack brought up the idea that
aliens were communicating telepathically
the children never mentioned it same
with the telepathic message that the
children allegedly received about how
the Earth was in danger because of
pollution the students didn't mention
that before Dr Mack joined the
investigation Dr Mack was an
environmentalist who was very worried
about climate change oh you believe in
UFOs but not climate change of course
the real thing and what is it for the
most part the teachers believe the
students so did Cynthia hind I believe
them
I believe they saw what they said they
saw I think that perhaps some have been
influenced by others and they've added a
little bit here and a little bit there
but basically they put Drew in their
drawings many things that I don't think
that they could know about Cynthia hind
wasn't just a UFO researcher she was the
mufon Continental coordinator for Africa
and the purpose of mufon is to
investigate UFO sightings and gather
data mufan is not a group of UFO nerds
posting on Reddit I do like those nerds
though I do too mufon tries to discredit
as many stories as they can so that
what's left is truly unidentified they
use the scientific method they observe
collect evidence and formulate
hypotheses they then conduct experiments
to confirm or refute each investigation
and they have a success rate of 95
percent improving their hypotheses and
this case elevated Cynthia Hines career
but Dr Mack on the other hand saw his
career suffer he wasn't just a child
psychiatrist who dabbled in UFO research
he was a Pulitzer prize-winning
professor and head of the Department of
Psychiatry at Harvard Medical School but
his colleagues didn't like Harvard being
attached to his UFO research they're
very embarrassed and embarrassed for the
profession and a little worried about
John himself what he's gone off the
rails as well John is a man of great
gift and great intelligence but he's
also a man of who tends to take on
enthusiasms and in this time he's gone
yeah gone too far we're worried about
him we hope you'll
pull himself together Harvard Medical
School actually formed a committee to
investigate Dr Mack this marked the
first time in the school's history that
a tenured professor and department head
was investigated without evidence of
misconduct after the investigation which
lasted for 14 months the dean of Harvard
issued a statement that Dr Mack was
allowed to study whatever he wanted the
most fundamental right that any academic
has is the right to be wrong
the statement is not very positive and
Dr Mack's reputation never recovered he
continued to investigate UFO encounters
and alien abductions for another 10
years but in 2004 he was in London to
give a lecture on September 27th Dr Mack
was walking home from dinner with
friends when he was struck and killed by
a drunk driver but his death was a
tragedy but there are people who
believed it was more Sinister than that
Dr John Mack was at the time one of the
most famous people researching alien
abductions he appeared on mainstream
television shows like Larry King live
and Oprah and some believe his high
visibility put his life in danger now
there is no evidence to support Foul
Play but it is interesting that on the
day John Mack was killed in England
three other John Max were also killed in
England and Dr Mack's family declined to
press charges Men In Black Adam that is
the suspicion but whether his death was
an accident or not Dr John Mack is just
one name and a long list of UFO
researchers and whistleblowers who die
early now those deaths could all be
coincidences but you know how I feel
about those
the aerial School encounter wasn't the
first time a UFO landed near a school
which was seen by multiple people on
April 6 1966 in Melbourne Australia
students from westall high school and
some local residents witnessed a UFO
land in an open field people described
the object as silver and saucer shaped
at about twice the size of a car after
about 20 minutes five aircraft probably
military Flew Over the area the object
then lifted off and disappeared
authorities tried to cover it up but the
craft was seen by over 200 people who
all told very consistent stories a
teacher who claimed to see UFOs hovering
over a Melbourne School says military
officials threatened to have him fired
if he ever spoke about the incident they
were threatening oh absolutely I was
threatened and if he spoke up clearly
you were drunk on duty and that will
have to be reported to the education
department and of course you'll lose
your job
the government had said it was just a
weather balloon uh where have I heard
this one before but representatives from
the military and government interviewed
interrogated Witnesses and took soil
samples from where the object landed
that doesn't sound like something you do
when a weather balloon crashes the
following year at Crestview Elementary
School in Miami students and teachers
heard a strange whistling sound overhead
looking up they saw four saucer-shaped
objects gliding in diamond formation the
craft disappeared for 20 minutes The
Returned changing their Direction the
sound they made was so loud it drowned
out the shouts of the teachers students
ran back inside terrified briefly
Vanishing again the UFOs rematerialized
for another flyby then in perfect Unison
they flipped onto their sides and flew
away at an unbelievable speed this event
was witnessed by 150 people nine years
later in Wales over a dozen students and
staff at broadhaven Primary School
reported a silver disc hovering over the
school they watched the object for a few
minutes until it darted away but later
that afternoon it returned this time
witnessed by even more people once again
it hovered for a few minutes before
Vanishing again the British government
said the UFO was actually a
meteorological anomaly a weird weather
event
[Music]
but in 2017 documents were found that
proved Not only was the government
taking the sighting seriously the UFO
was seen by military personnel and
pilots and air traffic controllers well
how long are these governments gonna
keep lying to their citizens eh I don't
know I guess until the citizens get sick
of it and do something about it
you sick of it yet
hey thanks again to enlisted for
sponsoring today's video don't forget to
click the link in the description to
download for free and get your exclusive
y-files bonus three days of Premium Time
and orders for troops and weapons thank
you so much for hanging out with me my
name is AJ that's cycle fish and let's
crack a racket this has been the y-files
if you had fun or learned anything do
him a favor and subscribe like comment
share I know I'm a broken record but
that stuff really helps the channel and
if you'd like to join a great community
of people that think just like us check
out the Wi-Fi's Discord there's
thousands of people on there it's a lot
of fun and it's free to join now special
thanks to our patrons who made this
episode possible you guys make every
episode possible I couldn't do this
without you I can't thank you enough and
if you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon
for as little as three dollars a month
you get all kinds of extra perks like
seeing the episodes early without
commercials without sponsors without any
of that stuff and you get early access
to goofy products like the Heckle fish
plushie
[Applause]
people
speaking of another great way to support
the channel is buy something from the
waffle store
[Music]
plushy stuffed fish Style toys that's
gonna do it until next time be safe be
kind and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
I took a stroll downtown this evening
when I heard music
yeah same old songs that I heard the
night before so I started running so I
wouldn't be too loud
[Music]
foreign
while we're Dancing In The Stream
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]